[Music]
okay
we have hit the finale of your
honor this episode was actually directed
by the man himself brian
cranston i have to say before jumping
into my review
this was one of the funnest shows i've
covered and i'm happy
that i've got to discuss it with all the
comments and everyone viewing i really
appreciate all your support
and i've had so much fun so let's just
finish strong here talking about this
because it's a very
interesting show because of many odd
decisions it makes
it's entertainingly in the beginning
pretty good and now it's gotten
entertainingly pretty bad but
i have mixed feelings about the finale
so first off it's making all these
criminal mistakes that shows just in
general are not supposed to make
this happen last week where they had a
clip that wasn't even in the show being
the previously on which is a total cheat
to the story
it's trying to pull a fast one on its
audience and then it just blew my mind
that they do something like this again
because
it ends with a cliffhanger in the last
episode right episode nine
remember if you watch the scene again
goes home sees michael
but fia here is laying on her couch
she's talking to her dad jimmy
and she's talking with him like okay now
it's time to meet adam and she's like
when do you want to actually see him and
he says
now so it cuts then to adam getting a
text from fia
and leaving to go see jimmy baxter and
michael saying goodbye
and it makes it like is he gonna see
adam again but the problem is they never
continue that
story this never really actually happens
in the timeline it's crazy that
it then opens episode 10 where no we're
actually
him looking for adam is adam open at the
river about it so it's like well did he
meet jimmy or not there
like what the hell is going on and what
i love about watching show finales
you start to expose a lot of story lines
that had no end game no payoff
what was the point of it so one of them
right away that stands out is that
michael flips out at the grandma for
telling adam about
what his mother did and then when adam
actually goes to see the dad they
are buddy buddy about it and
everything's okay and it just adds to
how much of a psychopath adam really is
and that
it's like okay this is something would
make sense for him to mope about and be
upset about but he's
you know okay whatever so you go well
what was the point of this
storyline with his mom dying and
cheating on his
dad with some of the desire gang at the
end of the day you could have just had
that the beginning of the show he got in
just a random accident
what was the point of this whole
connection with his mom dying i
don't understand it and when i'm talking
about finales exposing
storylines they didn't know really what
to do with and didn't have payoff or a
long game plan
that really is exposed with frannie's
story this love triangle she had with
adam and fia and that her
whole point in this show was to be the
one who transfers information
last episode to charlie so charlie knows
that adam's the one who actually
killed rocco that's it and that's just
not
good writing it's not good character
writing you don't want to make your
characters to serve the plot
you want the plot serving your
characters so you can literally say what
was the point of franny's storyline and
this
her finding out early on about adam and
they never really made her enough of a
threat to spill the beans and
expose what was really going on at the
school it really was just silly
and this episode confirmed that what i
had said
what i was worried would happen in that
episode that i actually did really like
when
jimmy actually finds out that michael is
involved in
his son's murder and covering it up that
that is when the show
might actually peak because you're all
exciting the beginning of the show where
it's this
chase of jimmy trying to get michael and
you can kind of
get away with not really sympathizing
with michael anymore because it was
still exciting to see this goose chase
happen but
once jimmy figured that out then it's
just the story of michael covering his
butt to a guy who's telling him what to
do
jimmy and it loses excitement and like i
said to keep it interesting you have to
have someone to root for then
and adam is not that guy so what this
finale also really exposes the
main main issue of this show as a season
whole is
how awful the character adam is because
jumping to the final scene here which
i'll get into more detail later but just
going to the final moments where adam's
dead
right and it's this tragedy they went
for and like i had also said a couple of
sets ago
they were kind of setting up this adam
and fia romeo and juliet thing and
turns out they go with the romeo and
juliet ending here but the problem is
you hate romeo in this story you like
juliet with fia so that worked
but you hate romeo it's not gonna work
you know adam has to be likable so
you're actually
happy when he gets shot i was and it's
like
no that's not gonna work to the feeling
you're supposed to feel
of the tragedy you're supposed to feel
with michael losing adam and
what did work was thematically with
michael that yeah
okay don't lie don't cover up selfishly
for yourself and for your son you think
you're doing something just like he
didn't even realize he's like oh my bad
person for covering for my
son against my own protection but
you like you know lee says to him in the
scene actually did like
she says like hey you know you had a
whole family killed
so yeah you are a piece of crap so right
there
you didn't have to still root for
michael because it still worked
dramatically at this man messed up and
he made these selfish choices now he's
paying the consequence
of his son dying who he's all this whole
time trying to protect but
to really make that scene be effective
and the end work was
to have us like adam and it wasn't there
that was the huge
issue here then you would have been
feeling sad in that last scene
then you would have been like wow this
is a really good tragedy here like
shakespeare but it's not shakespeare is
rolling in his grave at this one
but what impressed me about this show is
and all these flaws i'm pointing out
to be fair the acting's great all around
in particular that the actor of carlo
was amazing this episode so that's
something that keeps it watchable
you know and i've praised already of
course brian cranston but the actress
who plays the lawyer of fiona mckees
also really good here
but the show just kind of the second
half of the season got lost in this
carlos story and
getting him off guilty or not guilty and
there's a couple things in the story i
don't find believable and it's really
highlighted here in the first issue is
that
charlie knows that adam did it then
nancy finally figures this all out
that adam did it because charlie
confirms it was adam not michael to her
even though she
just figured out it was something to do
with michael and nancy's been
the character that's set up to be the
complete opposite of michael
actually being honorable and putting
justice first
but we're supposed to believe that
person is going to take this deal from
charlie like look you don't squeal on
adam and michael
and i'm running for mayor i'll make sure
when i get rid of these dirty cops that
the police department still has a good
image
that she would just phase out and take
that deal no way
nancy costello would still go and do the
honorable thing and try to get adam at
that moment so
that pissed me off unbelievable to me
and i
still cannot fathom as we're supposed to
think
michael is trying to make smart steps as
a judge to protect his son
so we're supposed to believe that
michael would think that
jimmy thinks he did it but if he gets
his son
cleared jimmy's just gonna let him live
his life happily ever after
even though he would think he's the one
who killed his son no way
i do not believe michael would think
that he's too smart it just doesn't make
sense
but just to put the the icing on the
cake here for adam's character
right he blows it it's so fittingly that
he's the one who messes it all up
for michael because he decides to go
watch this
case for some reason he wants to just
see his dad covering up for him but he
messes it up because when
michael's last players to play the
asthma video to
gain sympathy for carlo here to the jury
by making it just like oh look what
happened to this boy rocco
and kofi was there and he did this that
adam has to have an asthma attack here
and then
it makes jimmy and gina baxter connect
the dots
and it screws up everything in michael's
plan because now jimmy's like yeah okay
michael did what he had to do for me but
now i know it was really adam
so it's all for naught and i'm gonna
kill adam oh and the best
part and why adam's so hateable as a
character no one can relate
or feel for him is that when he goes to
this house party to celebrate
carlo getting off free here the minute
he gets
to the hotel he decides to turn his
phone off again
he loves to do this it's so convenient
for the plot
but it also suffers because it makes the
character an
idiot and you would just say to yourself
i would never do this even if you say
this kid's just crazy and just an idiot
still if you're in those shoes there's a
part of you that knows again you've been
warned by your father how crazy this
family is
and that you're going into their den now
why not just leave your phone on just in
case
it just doesn't make any sense you would
turn it off and then when this
inevitable climax happens
where jimmy calls michael it gets
exciting because michael's got to run
over there now
to save adam but it gets silly how it's
blocked here with
him running to the window then running
between the bodyguards not letting him
then back to the window and then
fighting with the bodyguards
it was so funny to me it was like
comical and like i said thematically it
worked it did work well with eugene now
being the one
to justfully try to go kill carlo by the
gun
he's the symbol of just the result of
michael's selfish behavior
but the only thing missing in this piece
to land this ending was just
to make adam somewhat likeable so we can
feel as the tragedy of oh man like you
got your son killed that we love no like
you're you're like you're happy he got
his son killed
again to be fair i had said i really
like the acting and it continues here in
this episode
i didn't think this was the worst
episode i really thought finally a good
scene which we haven't had a good scene
in a long time but i thought there was a
really good scene here
with lee and michael when they were just
talking about michael's character
and hearing both sides of it right there
for the audience to hear
and kind of get that message clear that
like yeah his mindset was i'm not
a bad person because i'm actually not
choosing
what i need but i'm choosing what my son
needs but she points out in doing that
you're actually
screwing over a whole family of people
and causing so much
death that was fine it was good acting i
enjoyed that but
overall it was silly and a lot of stuff
didn't land and
again what's so frustrating shows right
now as they get to these finales and
they don't know how to have payoffs and
you just wish sometimes they had a more
clear plan to go to the end and
again it's just a catastrophe to have
that cliffhanger last episode and then
this mysterious well what happened there
did adam end up going to see jimmy what
exactly happened it's like it never
happened i i don't understand
they feel like they just went week to
week with this thing and making it so
i'm gonna give the finale about a 7.5
i still think there was some
entertainment value here and as silly as
the end got you're still
kind of as you see like what's gonna
happen who's gonna kill who
but it has so many issues like i've
pointed out and
for the show i'm gonna give it as a
whole for the season a 6.3
i did think it started slow but then it
had a nice middle patch
and again it inevitably peaked once
jimmy found out what was really going on
with michael and
then it just went downhill and that's
why writing's so important in all shows
and you just wonder man if that writer's
room just thought
hold on let's make sure we really like
adam still throughout this
make him a little smarter so the
character can put themselves in his
shoes
and root for him we'd have a completely
different result in the show and it'd
probably be a pretty good show so with
all that said
let me know what you guys thought about
this finale and i also want to hear you
guys thought about the season what would
you give a season score
and what you believe was the final
verdict here just about everything
anything you want to say let it out now
and please stay with me if you enjoy
these reviews it means so much if you
subscribe and it helps me so much you
have no idea
i'll be doing a bunch of shows movies i
do celebrity interviews as well so
i appreciate any support and if you
really love what i do here i ask for a
two dollar monthly donation there's a
paypal link down below
that will give me the means necessary to
do this full time one day and i'll be
able to cover more shows and movies for
you guys
and please follow me at steve varley
show on twitter instagram for more of me
and i'll see you next time